first of all or what happened in the
earlier over this morning we're talking
is shortly before three o'clock when we
saw that epicenter just by Ramsgate four
point two in magnitude but that isn't
all is it because it was felt over a far
wider scale than that tell us what we're
looking at here why are you looking at
places where people reported they felt
the earthquake coming near the epicenter
people will have it will felt like a
lorry going past the house and covering
the building I don't think many people
have seen things falling over all the
lights swaying but just just a strong
vibration which we've only gone on for a
few seconds it was felt in France and
Belgium as well which isn't on this map
I supposed to share that we'll share our
tremors like that but all the way up as
we see there to pista and Stanford as
well so in terms of the major you saying
they're not big enough
really to cause major damage but
nevertheless quite significantly looked
in that way what would it is what we're
looking at well this is the trace on a
seismometer nearby in the UK and it's
calibrated for giving details the very
tiny tremors which go on a magnitude
fallen a bit earthquake has ten times
more vibration but a magnitude 3
earthquakes which is 10 times more
vibration in languages - so this isn't
mean here's a trace not much happening
and then it suddenly arrives and wham
wham wham wham wham but that was the
shaking and you can see probably did
only last just at just a few seconds and
of course we're not strangers to tremors
like that are we even though we think
it's remarkable we had one of a similar
magnitude but at first in 2007 get back
to 1382 we had one a five point eight
magnitude 1580 but won't kill people but
one day I mean because normally when we
say earth plates on the scale they don't
cause major structural damage or do they
it depends how close they are to the
surface and how close they are to a
built a furnace in the middle of English
Channel but even so people in London two
children London were killed by stones
falling from a roof on that one nobody
was killed in Folkston nine years ago
nobody was killed
today they were school say thankfully
nevertheless people did wake up and
realise what was going on in fact just
take a look at some of the reactions
we've had on social media you can see
there are people there tweeting saying
work to the house shaking my god but
earthquake
has freaked me out my house really [ __ ]
can the Kent earthquake really have been
a 4.3 magnitude whole house shook
interesting question how does this
compare to what happened in Nepal Matt
devastating airplane okay well Nepal was
magnitude 7.8 almost magnitude 8 so that
is almost 10,000 times stronger than the
Kent earthquake and that was very
shallow as well similar depth to this
actually but if you're close to the
Nepal earthquake where one plate is
grinding over another the movement near
the Himalayas lurch southwards by about
4 meters and the movement here would
have been about 4 centimeters